order of the speakers
today the for the for The Bu start from
415 correct so means 45 here I make the
uncomfortable Bell in case you're
upstairs we going to walk
please double check in your emails the
exact location but it's describ to you
you walk up in the front area a small
the I have a suggest that you get a
flute instead of the belt follow follow
the
flute
asay here this um uh next
speaker thank you uh everyone hearing me
okay first thank you for for the
invitation very happy to be here for
this great Workshop so today I will
present you some some work that I've
done with these Coors over the last
years about aquarium sing over trees and
inspired with all the work that I done
on complex re answering foral databases
but we apply it for
tree um so typically so tree is another
structure that you can use for
representing your data and typically the
classical way to query or to express
queries over there is not as it's not
for logic but is in general MSO and you
can express MSO for buan queries and
there is another formalism which is a
tri automata and there
is classical
um translation from
one and and then you have extension of
MSO where you can capture also
um different node of your tree so you
can use first order variables you return
toal of nodes and you also second order
free variables return total of sets of
nodes so here most of the talk will go
to the uh to the to the first kind of
queries where you have first order of
free
variables and typically there are
extension of Ms of queries and trees
where typically you want to do this kind
of counting number of solution and then
there are extension with a counting MSO
from Cel and there is query over
probalistic Tri presentation that we're
studying little more than 10 years now
and also question about enumeration of
solution over trees and there are
different paper that worked on that
already before and a big question B when
I started this kind of work it was B um
maintaining the answers or the
structures um this for for examp for
example enumeration through upd updates
of the trees so you not only want to
query but you also want to update also
quer so
typically the thing is what we know is
in general most of these questions are
um you can evaluate them in linear time
over the side of mat which is really
interesting because it's go completely
are the opposite of things that have
been done in relational databases where
typically you don't have one particular
uh language and in general you have to
find restrictive language and you have
to do a dichotomy to find the place
where you can do efficient query on and
so typically what we try I will try to
motivate and this is kind of L research
we we've done is the fact that to answer
this question is why MSO query
evaluation of Our Truth is simpler than
conjunctive quy complexity and evalution
of our relation database why what is
there a fundamental ground to explain
all these different result in one frame
so this is what we try we have tried to
do so the main thing that we have tried
to do is to say that how to represent
the solution of MSO query so we had a
partial offer a long time ago through
notion of provance for trees and at the
time what we show that this Provence for
mqu can be computed in near time and by
a circuit and also with a bonded tree
wi um typically what what I'm going to
talk about after you will see has a lot
of relation also to the work that then
have done on um on the context for that
relation basis where you try to have um
fine representation of the provence or
of the answer of the query that allow
you to do complex evaluation in in the
context of D was for a probalistic
evaluation
so this is same line of IDs we have not
really wanted anything but it's just the
fact that here you will see it works
very well for all Ms so typically what
we do we use a b Cy to present a set of
answer to a pattern to a query where um
typically we have signon where you have
variable Alpha for example and then you
say Alpha 6 is a variable and this
variable tell you that the variable of
my is mapped to not six and you can have
to PS of
SYM and typically we want to have a cap
a circuit that captures a set of Topol
in this
way um so
typically um the answer of the query are
the satisfying assignment of my
ciruit and typically what we want to
prove is that these circuits fall in
restrict restricted circuit classes that
allow uh for efficient complex
operation and of the question is uh the
task is given a br circuit how to
efficiently operate the complex
operation that we want over the
circuit so we go to B circuits so to
give you what is a bu circuit so you
have a output gate that tell you um the
the output and then you have L Gates
like for variables and their negation
and you have and and or and you have
some particular G sometime you can use
called decision
GES and so you have valuation the that
goes from the variable to 01 and
typically here we have an example and
you can propagate bottom up the
valuation and to tell you if this
valuation is Satisfied by my circuit and
then what you have to do is you have to
have that the Valu that you propagate at
the output gate have to be
one things and what you can do
your this way and then you map to one so
we know that this
Valu
by so an important notion that we need
for the rest of the talk is the notion
of assignment so typically what we want
to do is we want to have a a a more
concise representation of the file
Vision by looking at only the set of
variable map to one and I will explain
to you why is
important um so typically in general we
will consider much more assignment than
valuation and so typically one of our
task that we want to do is elimate all
SA
assignment for an input circuit is kind
of task that we want to
do so for that we will go to restic
classes that was proposed um nearly more
than 20 years ago uh that's called ddn
NF so D DN NF are disjunctive normal
form and the D first is a
deterministic deterministic mean
that um if I look at at two subcircuits
all the valuation of one will be DJ to
the valuation to the same so
typically here this part if I look at
the valuation of this part and valuation
of this part they are
disjoint for example here you see that
what you can notice is the fact that you
have the X have to appear X have to be
one have to be mapped to Z you're sure
that you have not uh you if you reason
here you sure that and you reason here
independently you will not reason on the
same assignment of Val a semantic
restriction this is a semantic yeah and
this is in general in to check but
typically what people have done is have
like so a line research is called
knowledge completion framework and and a
field typically people try to take an
CNF for example and try to compile into
this kind of circuit so this is one line
of research here you will see that we
also sometime so the work of done for
example show that for some P constuctive
queries um you have this property
automatically and this is what we try to
do and the de composability is the fact
that when you have a hand you talk about
you split the variables on the left and
the
right and also we need some Notions
course most it mean that
if you look at your subcircuit here you
see that you have a variables that Y at
Pi here and a w that appear here but not
in the other SE typically when is most
you need that you need to talk about all
the same variables here and all the same
valuable this is important for some of
the
result the same most is not something
aom you can check it but it's not
something automatic that you can have
and the last one is zero Suess semantic
ciruit is the fact that you don't talk
about valuation but you talk only about
assignment so typically you don't have
negative literals you have only positive
one and everything which doesn't appear
in your in in your in your circuit just
has to be assigned to
zero so what we know about quering
circuit so the first thing is I will
talk about summar just a little is the
fact that if I take a cative summing and
I want and I I give a set of assignment
of the variable like a cost function
that go from the variables to the
literals of x to K I want now to
generalize it to say what is the value
for my circuit okay and what I do I do
the sum of all the all the assignment
satisfi by S and I assign all the to all
the liter assign to one I give them
their value and to the one that to
variable assign to zero I give value
assign to the
negative okay
and what we can prove we can prove with
a smooth dnf circuit if I do that I can
compute it in
lout typically the example I've shown
before when you check the valuation it
just you take the BL summar ring and you
just do the evaluation it's exactly you
can do and you just
generalize so typically we don't need
smoothing for particular kind of
functions called positive cost function
means that when the negative liter
Associated always to the neutal
I don't if I the case I I just one one
is one is negative when I multiply in
metal it doesn't change anything so all
the information is brought by the value
of the
positive and uh in particular we can do
counting evaluation and probalistic
evaluation can be done in time
for I just want to give you an example
to show you why smoothing is important
so here you see that is my example from
before and you see that it's not
Smo I can start to do the evaluation so
here I want to count the number of
valuation and here you see that um if
you count and you reason here I have
what I have that so I can count here I
have one particular valuation but I can
take omega or not omega independently
and to add to that and you will do so I
have two valuation here and the same way
I have y that is not appearing so if I
reason about that I have this one plus
TW I can add I can put y to one or zero
dependently so I have two and then I I I
can add the I can add both because there
a determinism and I can add four I will
do how to show you how we do that in a
Boton up inductive Manu so you map the
literal to one because here is to and
then what I do I associate the end to
mation to the all to the plus of the and
you do the propagation
typic with a multiplication I multiply
give me
one the next step I will multiply here
which is one
here here you see that because it's not
smooth in some way if I just add things
I will only have two mappings which is
wrong so what I have to do I have to
count the fact that here I had the W and
not the Y and here I have the Y and not
the W so the smoo thing give me the fact
that have to take smoing May here we do
that on online so smoing but in general
what you want to do is Smo one for all
and then after
that so moving can be done overhead yeah
it can be offline here I just wanted an
example to see why is it important to do
that but of also it doesn't increase the
size of the C you will is a part of a
next slide how cost the
sming and so typically we do the Smo
thing and then we add an for
and the thing is you take any summar in
works that's a good
thing comitative
summary the thing also what we've done
is about ination because this was and we
wanted to reprove that so when we
understood that we say okay we can do
probalistic and we ask okay can we do
other things that works on trees very
well typically at the time he was in
numeration when we started the work you
ask it was already proed by two
different approach and we say okay can
this approach
can so what we do is we tell that okay
for trees so when we look for trees and
we went to the dnf and we we had to work
a little on it and typically we have to
have these zero suppress semantic dnf
circuits and we what we know is the fact
that we can enumerate it satisfying the
assignment with a prepressing linear on
C and the L linear in the size of
assignment and I will show you after
that that the fact that it's not on the
valuation but the assignment is really
important you want to use
for and so typically we have to deal
with different problem dealing with a
this part of the SE with anti assignment
some memory usage that can you have to
be careful some in the general case you
can have a linear memory usage and
things like that in practice what we
want to do is I don't only enumerate the
signment but I enumerate something a
little bigger which is I enumerate the
the the variable gate and the end Gates
of the acceptance sub of the paral
assment I take a note I look at all the
partial assignment and what I do is when
you do the a proof for showing this
parment is true you see then with the
end you can combine thing but in the all
you just choose one only one branch in
some way all these all that become a
unary node you just merge them one and I
just look at these
Tres and typically you have to find good
structure to do that but you can't do
that and one key thing that is the fact
that we need a structure that is a POS
sex structure where I can do this
folding operation in gr of one I can add
an element I can give an
element if you do that just any list
anything works but the thing is
important that you can do a union of
these two structure that is doesn't
depend all their all their and so
typically sh propos a structure like
that what is very important is so a new
data structure created for this exist
yeah well I mean like here I just
described you in a more IPI way that
what you need for proof and we propose
one particular kind of implementation
for that but you could have another
one it's the Practical one this has been
implemented like we have not
implemented something that we would like
to do at some
point uh the thing is important is also
that the preprocessing the way that we
build thing are in a bottom of
evaluation in a linear way and what we
can do also is we a lot of people have
worked as you on rank eneration recently
for conjunctive CES and you know of
conjunctive CES we had a great talk
about that also before and to typically
we ask ourself what we can do with the
DNN so what we have we have that this
Zer supress semantic cirquit we use a
strong sub monoton notion ranking
function on the par assignment meaning
that you only put weight on the positive
part wa on the negative part mean you
just count things that appear in the
solution because and what we can prove
we can prove that we canate the
following with the following order
following their cost in preprocessing
linear in the in the circuit and delay
that depends of the maximal sign of the
of the assignment and also K is a number
of of of of solution that you already so
more you enumerate more you have to
pay and in practice we we do the same
thing we we rank enumerate the sub trees
in the same way that we do for for for
the enumerate case and the main
difference is a key structure that we
use and here we use broad cues so what
are these bide cues are very beautiful
structure that there are persistent
priority cues where have the fing put
can add a pair element value to in in
Conant time I can have the maximal in
Conant time so this is a classical thing
that you have that really important
thing is the fact you can do me of two
set in also constant time and the
classical thing with this priority to is
the fact that delation is where you pay
your
cost so this is the kind of result that
we had in some way we reproved in some
way that things that we are known in
different um context and we prove that
for this kind of cites a lot of things
works well with a little work with some
really complex structure for this one we
are very very happy that we found this
structure because it's not a want to
do and typically this is what we have
the thing I wanted to remark is what
caus the smoothing because most of the
time you need a smoothing at least for
reasoning with your Su smoothing is in
general the bad news is fact that the
size of the new circuit is in the Square
because you need to represent a lot of
things all the variables possibly you
have to look at all
the the thing is you have different um
better case if you have some particular
can of ddn a structure one
umine worked on that and show that you
are close to the to linear but you're
still a little
above you want to so if if you want to
have linear preprocessing and you need
to smooth this part you need to pay a
price that is a little more than linear
but not too
much we can ask and also what we proved
in a in a paper when we do ination is
for other one is called order dnf uh you
can do that in in linear time but you
need a particular notion of gates that
are reinvented to to have a compress
compress way to present the
value so the the question now is how go
back to from to the question now is how
I construct really circuit representing
Z so at give me an automata with first
order variables um there are way to
generate that but and we want to what I
I know I can build smooth circuits
capturing exactly the set of top off in
the output of a and this way I can if I
do that I can reip I do that in linear
time in my in my my my tree and then
after that you reason on on this still
linear on your tree your ciruit and if
you want to compute something over over
over Tri which is a summering you can do
it just by by reusing is important here
is the fact that the SM thing is already
done during the so you don't have to r
that and the second thing is the fact
that for also Tre automata you can do
also build a tree in zero supress amount
in capturing exactly the set of to on
the
out
so here what is important this one is
used for the numeration so here in
general what you have to to notice is
the fact that the number of variable
that you
have are the number variable of my
automata multiply by the variable by the
by the N of my tree which POS a problem
because typically um if I look at
valuation a valuation is of size length
of my tree of the size of my tree so if
I just do resoning over uh the valuation
I will not obtain the result that I want
that is linear might that will the delay
will be constant or the delay will be
logarithmic because typically I just
have to put all the valuation that is
already linear in the cetric so it won't
be able to do that I won't be using just
valuation go back to the result uh so
that is why we use so we are in the
first order case we know that the the
number of variables that are assigned to
one
is bonded by the by the number of
variables in
my I know that this part for an
assignment its
size is only in size of the query and
therefore uh if I at only your data
complexity um I'm just
Conant so this is why we need this zero
Suess semantic um to be to ensure in
some way that we are we we just numerate
the the minimum number of information
that we need for for for for going back
to the
rest and I just want to show you a
little how we build
that so typically here I just want to
take any pair of not my tree for it's
very simple thing I do the cartisan
produ my Tre but I just want to show how
you do that you have the state where you
know if your sign if you have not the
sign variable your sign of alpha your
sign beta and you s alpab and you have
rules to fact that okay if I if I assign
on my left sub tree I find mty in in my
my right sub my right sub tree and I
don't assign anything on my current node
then the state of this note is better
the same way I assign beta before on my
left tree the mty on my right tree and
now I said Alpha to n then I go to the
Al it's very simple and this a classical
thing just classical rules for um for
for and and how can and now I will show
you how to build the the automata for
that so the circuit typically we'll do
that by induction and I have a no
particular variable that say Alpha to
end this is the one I want to build and
also I assume that I have all gates for
different state of the previous nose to
the left and the different states that
are already computed so this is the
output of output subcircuits for uh when
I go to empty M State empty T Alpha Beta
Alpha bet and after that I just apply
the transition function in the
classic that okay I use the first rule
okay I am beta and and I'm State beta
instead n i do the nend because then I
have to compose it and after
that if I don't select alpha n i just go
to and the same way now for the second
rule I find data mty but now I choose Al
Alpha i m to Alpha and then I can
create and this man just can do it and
has all the good properties
that this so just expressing in natural
way the transition function that you
have all the runs that you
have and therefore we can reprove all
the for complex qu that we are
done
uh and what is important I said we
notice that the size of the correspond
is this is very important because we
cannot do that
evation and the new result that we have
is the fact that now if I do that for
rank enumeration I can do that with
a
produced so kind of similar result that
you
have
the main difference
is and just want to talk two minutes
about updates the thing is Al the kind
of structure and the kind of way we
compute it is bottom up and works very
well uh when we want to modify the tree
and what we want to maintain we want to
maintain this C and how much it
cost you do updates Rebel and and you
don't want to to you want to maintain
this data cure and there are before
results that look at
that and typically the the the thing is
for text we knew that there were
something efficient but typically for
words we had this
complexity and the thing is now if we re
relabel we know how to do that we have a
structure that we know that we have the
the delay that we have before for
eneration and for the update we need a
log time and so typically how it works
what we can see we see that if I want to
update my circuit that where I build for
q&t when I do an update of my tree what
I have to do is I have to do an update
on C that I have to update C and it
depends only on the depth of
c and typically then the problem now is
the depth of T can be linear on T and
there are a lot of nice methods where
you can rebalance your tree in know
where to to to have the dep that is not
the same so there if you just need reing
we just need to balance at the beginning
and we don't need to do anything after
that and there are very nice thing that
say that I can do rebalancing with
logarithmic time and also results
uh and very soon very recent ones uh so
that you can uh maintain your presenter
VI Tre in log
Square true and this recent one which is
under submission by some some some some
of my course I'm not there I'm not
thiser very nice algeb representation
for trees
for nice
and and therefore we have in some this
is where we can adapt and because
everything is we everything we have done
before is is a bottom up evaluation you
see that you just have to propagate over
the dep of the and then after that the
dep of the circuit to maintain the
structure so just to finish I um it is
was known that complex evaluation of MSO
ques of TR can be done efficiently um
the thing is we try to present a uniform
framework to wellknown results based on
par kind of cits that are smoo Z Super
semantic
D and for for for me in some way the
philosophy is why it works on trees is
because you can have this representative
solution for all the queries and not
only for fragment of
them and also we show that because of
our techniques we we can do incremental
maintenance of the structure on did also
good and typically there are a lot of
things that have been done recently in
relational databases for different kind
of query and like unform sampling direct
access uh generalization of animation of
weighted MSO but for trees and all these
kind of things and typically we think
that a good answer a good approach for
doing that is to to look at this problem
over this
dnf more however these dnf are not used
only in in in databases but they're
using a lot of
different framework for AI and for also
different applications and typically
when we find this rul is not an impact
on for for MSO but for more General cont
thank
you
any
questions sorry silly question but that
Islander algorithm for for for re
balancing asum has a gigantic
astronomical constant right as all
Bolder algorithms
have no but yeah the thing is there
heretical the thing doesn't work in
practice this is not a criticism I just
want to make sure that this the usual
kind of fixed payability thing want just
yeah for the typically for it's a good
it's a good question because I'm
not linear on the time yes there is
something but it's still you know like
this balancing doesn't depend on the
query so here you just have
something the tree and I don't know I
don't know the Conant I it's not it's
not easy algorithm to do that in really
linear time exponential start
what what would it be exp um in in the
tree with of some underlying structure
that shows up somewhere but we're doing
this on a tree so I think the would be
some Conant right so be
exponential the because I said this this
this this is only depend on the tree
doesn't depend on the okay I said but
not important actually you know no the
thing that you have to pay is the fact
that MSO query here we assume that we
can translate to deta and there this is
question how you express a so this there
there is a big there is a big constant
for in how you express it but but most
thing
there just depend of the but this this
thing I don't know I've never not
implemented yet okay let's than
again
I think question is for this